[Music]
we screen tested the three of them
together to make sure that they all had
this chemistry which immediately was
obvious in the first screen test
remember guys get closer to her as she
finds out the information and action
i never thought to look in here
i checked this out first term for a bit
of light reading this is life
shut up your filth comes around the
corner any second now at least 50 points
off gryffindor
i knew it
here it is
nicolas flamel is the only known maker
of the sorcerer's stone
the what
oh honestly don't you two
all right good job
it's lovely seeing you yeah this is
surreal isn't it how do we all feel
being
back and talking about this a really
emotional
obviously and b
um it feels like no time has passed and
loads of time has passed
[Music]
think of that powerful memory
make it
the happiest you can remember
it feels like no time has passed
and loads of times past
i think this is the perfect time to sit
down with everyone and reminisce
the thing that scared me the most
was the implication that the most
meaningful thing in our life was done
and there's something so joyous about
seeing everyone
and be like
there wasn't though
one of the highlights of my part was
when i had to pretend to be hermione
pretending to be better tricks i don't
like to be kept waiting i've still got
their teeth actually i'll put them in if
you want
my sister has children who have been
around 10 11 12 and i said math i don't
know about this voldemort what you're
being asked to play voldemort
you've got to do it
i wouldn't be the person i am without so
many people here
it's a very overwhelming thing because
i've watched you go up and i've seen
kind of every stage of your life
when things get really dark and times
are really hard there's something about
harry potter that makes life richer it's
a strong bond that we'll always have
[Music]
we're family and we will always be part
of each other's life
[Music]
[Music]
you